Transformers made Shia LaBeouf a mega
star but then he followed that up with
legal troubles resentment and some
generally bizarre behavior
Shia LaBeouf had a complicated childhood
his parents were both artists so the
family wasn't exactly rolling in cash
his father in particular wasn't always
Pleasant to be around he was a
professional clown who had a history of
drug addiction following his military
service in Vietnam after his parents
separated an adolescent LaBeouf began
mapping out a career that he hoped would
help with finances he was inspired by a
friend who seemed to have it all after
an appearance on Dr Quinn Medicine Woman
so he started doing stand-up during
which he sported overalls and a bowl cut
in front of a room full of adults
looking for a laugh he managed to
quickly make a name for himself with the
mouth of an adult on the body of a kid
LaBeouf's next move was Landing an agent
by pretending to be his own 50 year old
English manager the agent that he hired
helped significantly by paying his
family's rent driving him to auditions
and booking in his breakout role
at the age of 12 Shia LaBeouf landed the
role that would change his life forever
on the Disney Channel sitcom Even
Stevens he played Lewis the youngest
sibling of the titular Stevens Family
the show ran for three seasons 65
episodes and a full length made-for-tv
movie from 2000 to 2003. in 2003 Le buff
was honored with a Daytime Emmy Award
for outstanding performer in a
children's series the same year he
starred in the movie Holes alongside big
name actors like Sigourney Weaver and
Jon Voight the latter of whom took Le
Buffon as a mentee Foles also got the
attention of a certain major Hollywood
director by the name of Steven Spielberg
after he watched the movie with his kids
Spielberg recommended Le buff for a
certain upcoming flick about alien
robots that he was producing
it may be one of the biggest franchises
around today but when the first
live-action Transformers came out in
2007 there was plenty of skepticism
about whether or not it could actually
rake in the Box the idea of adapting a
Hasbro toy line and cartoon from the
1980s into an action Blockbuster wasn't
exactly a slam dunk proposition but it
had some serious industry power behind
it with Steven Spielberg producing and
Michael Bay directing Shia LaBeouf was
cast in the lead human role as Sam
Witwicky who has unknowingly inherited a
connection to an ongoing war between
extraterrestrial robots with Decepticons
set on taking over the world Sam helps
the Autobots led by Optimus Prime save
the planet with a heavy dose of fast
cars military weapons and loads of CGI
Transformers managed to be a massive
success collecting over 700 million
dollars at the worldwide box office and
suddenly Shia LaBeouf found himself
catapulted into Mega stardom the boys
pheromone level suggests he wants to
mate with the female
around the time the Transformers came
out Shia LaBeouf was being touted as the
next big thing in Hollywood Steven
Spielberg doubled down on his faith in
the young thespian by casting him as the
son of Indiana Jones as the Director
raved a Time Magazine Shia was within
everyone's reach he's Every Mother's Son
every father's spitting image every
young kid's best pal and every girl's
possible dream 2007 was undeniably quite
the year for lab in addition to one of
the Summer's biggest Blockbusters he
also starred in the Thriller Disturbia
and the animated penguin comedy Surfs Up
but then the following year Indiana
Jones and the kingdom of the Crystal
Skull wasn't exactly the most beloved
entry in that long-running franchise as
the actor bemoaned to the Los Angeles
Times I feel like I dropped the ball on
the Legacy that people loved and
cherished
Le buff returned to play sandwich Wiki
again for two Transformer sequels 2009's
Revenge of the Fallen and 2011's Dark of
the Moon but those experiences were
filled with conflict as he arrived on
the set of Revenge of the Fallen with an
injured hand after being arrested for
suspicion of drunk driving the charges
were ultimately dropped but the injury
resulted in some necessary script
changes making matters worse the
2007-2008 Writers Guild of America
strike resulted in Revenge of the Fallen
beginning production without a finalized
script despite that setback and less
than Stellar reviews it still earned
over 800 million dollars at the global
box office but LaBeouf wasn't exactly
happy with the end result as he put it
in an interview we weren't making a
movie to make a good movie we were
making a movie to hit a date two years
later Dark of the Moon broke the one
billion dollar Mark at the global box
office and was slightly better received
critically but before it even hit
theaters Le buff had already announced
that he would be moving away from the
franchise no no no
the news that LE buff was exiting
Transformers was a shock to nearly
everyone the franchise had made him one
of Hollywood's most bankable young stars
but he chose to use that cloud to pursue
more artistic independent films instead
as he told the Hollywood reporter's
Awards chatter podcast in 2019 I don't
think there was any acting going on this
was like personality there was no acting
going on for the huge front half of my
career this was all just my personality
exhibited on a camera the key
transitional moment for LaBeouf's career
happened when he starred in 2010's Wall
Street money never sleeps as he recalled
I was trying to shake off Disney I was
trying to shake off Blockbusters as for
the fourth Transformers movie Michael
Bay resisted Studio pressure to recast
Le Buff's role and instead opted to
bring in Mark Wahlberg as a fresh face
for the franchise as it turned out Shia
LaBeouf's legal troubles weren't the
only thing plaguing the Transformers
films as his co-star Megan Fox wasn't
exactly comfortable while making them to
put it mildly in a 2009 interview with
Wonderland magazine she revealed that
Michael Bay was a nightmare to work with
and she even compared his directing
style to Adolf Hitler she was fired from
the franchise but she and Bay would
eventually bury the hatchet and reunite
for 2014's Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
this unsettling treatment wasn't ignored
by Le buff who admitted that he had a
romantic fling with his co-star as he
explained to the Los Angeles Times Megan
developed this Spice Girl strength this
woman empowerment that made her feel
awkward about her involvement with
Michael who some people think is a very
lascivious filmmaker the way he films
women he continued Mike films women in a
way that appeals to a 16 year old
sexuality and I think Megan never got
comfortable with it when Mike would ask
her to do specific things there was no
time for fluffy talk and the one thing
Mike lacks is tact after his time with
Transformers LaBeouf's controversial
reputation would only grow and grow in
February 2013 a Broadway production of
the play orphans was canceled after he
reportedly quit over what was later
revealed to be a fight between him and
his co-star Alec Baldwin that fight gave
fire to the rumors that LE buff also got
into an altercation with Tom Hardy on on
the set of the 2012 film Lawless a year
prior but as Le buff claimed during an
appearance on the YouTube talk show hot
ones there was nothing to that story
Beyond some playful wrestling I look up
to Tom as an actor and I respect him as
an actor he has a different appetite for
you know being a method actor than I do
then in 2014 Le buff was arrested after
causing a scene at a Broadway production
of Cabaret this was just the beginning
of a string of arrests for disorderly
conduct as he again faced charges in
2015 and 2017. the latter of those
arrests was a self-admitted new low for
Le buff as he was caught on camera
accusing a black police officer of
arresting him for being white and that
wasn't the end of his run-ins with the
law as he was charged with misdemeanor
battery and petty theft in 2020.
in 2016 the always candid Shia LaBeouf
was making headlines again after an
interview with variety saw him insulting
his work with Steven Spielberg as the
actor put it I grew up with this idea if
he got to Spielberg that's where it is
you get there and you realize you're not
meeting the Spielberg you dream of
you're meeting a different Spielberg who
was in a different stage in his career
he's less a director than he is a
company Le buff went on to say that the
only movie he appreciated making under
Spielberg was the first Transformers as
he declared everything has been so
meticulously planned you got to get this
line out in 37 seconds you do that for
five years you start to feel like not
knowing what you're doing for a living
however the actor later retracted his
statements and admitted that Spielberg
opened a lot of doors for him
despite all his misdeeds and lack of
tact Shia LaBeouf has managed to build
himself the artistic career of his
dreams since his Blockbuster days he's
taken on more character-driven work in
the likes of such films as Fury Borg vs
Mcenroe and honeyboy he's also
challenged himself with a move into the
director's chair adding a few short
films and music videos to his resume and
one of his most notable projects a
motivational speech titled hashtag
introductions became a popular internet
meme do it
just do it
Le buff has also branched into some
other otter artistic Pursuits in 2015 he
broadcast a live stream of himself
watching all of his own movies he
followed that up a year later by
spending 24 hours inside an elevator and
going on a journey across America where
fans could pick him up and drop him off
wherever they chose unfortunately Le
buff has also become equally famous for
his plagiarism a short film that the
budding director debuted at the 2012
Cannes Film Festival was discovered to
be a ripoff from a comic book written
and illustrated by Daniel Klaus Le buff
later tweeted an apology which was
itself discovered to be plagiarized
subsequently two comic books that he'd
previously released were also condemned
for plagiarism
LaBeouf's ongoing troubles have only
seemed to get worse over time in 2020 a
former romantic partner is singer FKA
Twiggs filed a lawsuit alleging a range
of Acts including violence towards her
and shooting guns at stray dogs she also
accused him of not disclosing an STD
infection to her LaBeouf has since owned
up to the fact that his behavior in that
relationship was disgusting during a
2022 appearance on the real ones podcast
he admitted I was a pleasure-seeking
selfish self-centered dishonest
inconsiderate fearful human being I hurt
that woman you know and in the process
of doing that I hurt many other people
and many other people before that woman
LaBeouf also attempted to credit his
former partner for positively changing
his life as he put it had she not
intervened in my life and not created
the Avenue for me to experience ego
death I'd either have a really mediocre
existence or I'd be dead in full
Shia LaBeouf now finds himself in a
struggle for Redemption becoming a
father is one experience that has helped
him recalibrate his life as he explained
on the real one's podcast it's almost
like having the ultimate parole officer
I need somebody to keep me accountable
despite that effort LaBeouf once again
found himself at the center of a
high-profile Feud after leaving the cast
of The 2022 film don't worry darling he
and director Olivia Wilde have offered
differing takes over whether he quit or
was fired nevertheless his career has
remained alive as he set to star in the
2024 Francis Ford Coppola directed
sci-fi epic megalopolis meanwhile the
Transformers movies have continued to
truck along without their former star
with the latest entry rise of the beasts
arriving in theaters on June 9th 2023
the plan is to launch a new Trilogy of
Transformers films separately
Transformers 1 set for release in 2024
will act as a prequel to The established
franchise and yet another movie inspired
by the toy line is reportedly in the
works under director Angel Manuel Soto
if you or someone you know is dealing
with domestic abuse you can call the
National Domestic Violence Hotline at
1-800-799-7233 you can also find more
information resources and support at
their website
foreign